[Music]
let's go to andy in harrisburg what's up
andy
hey dr john how are you i'm good what
are you doing
oh right now i'm just actually sitting
on the beach um in my car so that we're
not disrupted by the ocean sounds but uh
yeah enjoying a family vacation well
thanks for taking time away from from
the water
for this knuckleheaded podcast that's
fantastic
of course all right let's let's uh let's
solve world hunger what's up
it's not quite as deep as that but i
appreciate you taking time to
navigate this with me
um so i'll try to condense this
basically what's going on is my future
sister-in-law feels rejected after we
asked her and my brother-in-law not to
bring their dog to our one-year-old's
birthday party
yeah
it sounds simple but unfortunately it's
kind of blown up in our face no it's not
simple at all because you're dealing
with madness
yeah it's not simple at all
yeah wow
they chose not to come to the party um
which
initially was kind of like offensive to
us because we were like no we just want
you to be there like we just don't want
your dog there and we want you guys to
come and so it felt to us like they were
kind of like choosing their dog over our
daughter hey hold on hold on hold on
they 100 dead
yeah it's not a feeling it's a it's a
it's a it's it's data it's true
they chose their dog over you
or they chose the principle of nobody's
going to tell me what to do
over
your boundaries
right i think
it stems a little deeper than that for
them though i think that like this
response like was triggered by something
probably in my sister-in-law's past i i
don't know for sure but she doesn't like
their doesn't matter doesn't matter
don't don't get in her head and try to
figure out why she's doing what she's
doing and where it's coming from and all
that doesn't matter yeah you're gonna
make yourself crazy doing that
and you and your husband are going to
get into fights over that you're going
to end up crawling you ever seen the
movie being john malkovich
no i haven't okay it's about they they
find a secret portal behind a
file cabinet in an office that gets them
inside of john malkovich's head it's a
bananas movie it's one of the most
incredible movies you can ever see in
your life it's awesome but
it's madness everybody goes crazy
and don't get in her head doesn't matter
yeah she chose her dog over over your
kid
yeah full stop that's what happened
so i guess basically we're at the point
where we're hearing from other family
members um two months down the road
where we thought this was you know kind
of all in the past we're hearing from
family members that they're feeling
rejected still and now they're choosing
not to attend family matters that we're
at
and i
in no way thought that this would become
this big of a thing and i i don't want
that is that because you're a rational
human being
well
maybe yes i actually don't want them to
feel hurt and i you can't control
madness you cannot control madness
i know you can't i'm so sorry i'm so
sorry you can't control madness
i just hate that it's affecting like the
rest of the family at this point yes
that's fine we
love them and we love our family and we
want them to be there and feel welcomed
by us and by everyone because they are
but now they're choosing to avoid us
instead of just talking to us about
what's hurting them and hearing from
other people that they're hurting it's
hurtful to us because
we feel like just talk to us like we're
all adults like we just want to hear
what's up and have you ever one of you
all called them
so we actually didn't call them but we
met we tried to meet up with them for
brunch we're actually about two hours
apart they're in a different city and
they don't own a car
um so it was really more on us to like
why don't they own a car
um they live in philadelphia so they
just don't really need one
they walk and you know take public
transit so
um yeah i think basically we had you
know basically planned to have brunch
with them just spur of the moment since
we were going to be in the city and
my sister my future sister-in-law chose
not to show up and initially i thought
what was just last minute she probably
just like had other plans but then
my brother-in-law told us that like she
just chose not to come and that she was
sleeping in
and like we had our daughter with us
thinking like okay like they'll want to
see her like even if they don't want to
see us shortly they'll want to see her
after not being able to be at her party
um but yeah apparently there was still
hurt stemming from that
um okay so
let me be
super direct is that cool
yeah this has very little if not nothing
to do with the dog right
yeah we've realized that this is a woman
who does not like you and does not like
your husband or does not like your unit
or doesn't like anybody taking attention
from her precious little fiance
and wants her world exactly how she
wants her world and has a picture of it
and will not deviate from it in fact
we'll act like a child a a elementary
school child not even a middle schooler
i've got one of those this is an
elementary school move
and
there is literally nothing you can do
about it except treat her with dignity
respect and go on with your day
you'll have to grieve this like crazy
because you probably had a dream that
you and your brother's wife would become
best buds and she'd be the greatest aunt
ever
and you maybe even met her at a family
party once or twice and thought she's
hilarious and fun or weird and eccentric
or whatever
and you created a picture of what life
was gonna be and that picture's not
gonna come true
and you're going to just have to grieve
it and i would be really direct with my
other family members
i am sorry they chose
their dog over our kid
and if they choose to not want to be
around us because we have boundaries
then that's the choice they make and
unfortunately if you they choose if your
rest of your family chooses that
golly that's going to feel like you're
on an island but your boundaries are
still your boundaries and if you start
now trying to chase making other people
happy like that in your family
man that's a recipe for disaster
yeah you know what i mean
i hate this for you
i wish i could just be we could all
laugh and be like uh just call her and
tell her whatever
yeah so i mean i guess like my husband
and i are at the point where
we feel like
it's worth trying to mend at least
attempting like we would really like to
still have a relationship with them even
if it is just the three times a year we
see them
they don't want a relationship with you
but i think they do they just are hurt
by this like
they don't
have they have they called you and said
we're hurt by this
no
have they written you a letter just said
hey we were caught off guard we don't
have kids this our little dog is our
only kid and it it sounds lame but it
means something to us
and
it just bummed us out that you put that
did they do that
no i wish they would have no they talk
crap about you to other people they're
trying to rally troops to their side
they don't even show up when you drive
two hours to be on their town with your
new baby
they don't show up
they don't want to be in a relationship
with you
and i hate to be the guy that's telling
you that
you want them to want to
but they don't what they want is their
world on their terms and they can have
it
but you've chosen to not meet some of
those terms and so they took their ball
and went home
yeah
and i hate that
yeah because it's so immature and it's
so lame
and i want you to hear notice something
i've never asked you one time why you
did not want that dog in your house you
know why doesn't matter
does not matter
you ask for them to not bring their dog
who cares why
you know what i mean
yeah
a little guilty just because it's
silly to like ask them not to bring
their dog and unfortunately we did
communicate it like only
it was a little less than a week ahead
of time so we had told them about the
party months in advance and then
found out they were going to bring their
dog and ask them not to um and so that's
like obviously where all this stems from
but i some of me feels like this is
deeper obviously steeper than that but
somebody feels like there has to be
something else that they're frustrated
with us about for this to become this
big
but i don't i like i'm just thinking
like what could that be and like what
it's very common for little things like
your brother is talking about well my
sister when they got married fill in the
blank or my sister is awesome she does
this and they have kids and my
brother-in-law's doing this
and unfortunately it's common
that
a
new person marrying into a family feels
threatened by that relationship between
a brother and a sister
feels threatened by that relationship
between the brother and other members of
their family
and so they don't blow it up they do
sometimes but that's easy to spot right
that's simple
they don't blow it up from the
one up position right you can't go see
her i don't like they don't do that
they just
they they blow it up from they drown it
from the one down position they just
grab the rope of the boat and slowly
pull it under water
i'm just not gonna go
i just don't feel like it i'm
uncomfortable i'm tired it's not gonna
go
and then eventually your brother will
get tired showing up to things by
himself and he'll just stay home too
right yeah
so
it's actually my husband's brother but
yeah i mean we're still yeah
i guess like
i understand what you're saying how like
it seems like they don't want to be in
our lives but at the same time we'd like
to at least try to amend it even though
they haven't really put foot forth
effort to we'd really like to try and i
feel like
personally kind of feel like we owe it
to my mother and father-in-law to try
because they're the ones that like told
us kind of how this was all playing out
so now you're responsible for how your
in-laws feel
because they don't have the courage to
tell their kids y'all are being
ridiculous
put the dog in a dumb kennel and go see
your your niece
yeah i mean i kind of wish that was
their response but it was you can't
manage this and i hate that now listen
i'm with you
hear me say this
pretend you're the guy calling me and
say hey i dated this girl for a while
and then all of a sudden she quit
talking to me
and um
i reached out and we were gonna get
together for coffee and then she just
said i'm sleeping in
and um i had something really important
to show her and she's like i just blew
me off
i think she really still loves me
um
but i i'm gonna try one more overture
i would say this she doesn't but go for
it anyway okay so if i'm you i would do
some i would make sure i'd crossed all
the t's and dot all the eyes
yeah
just because you told them a week ahead
of time
doesn't mean you're at fault because you
didn't know about the dog until a week
ahead of time because if somebody's
gonna bring a pet to somebody a
stranger's house usually they they let
you know
my parents do that every year they have
a little wiener dog
named rachel
and
they call and say hey is it cool for
bringing the dog sometimes it is last
year we were like hey can you just board
that dog
and they're like yeah no problem and
they boarded the dog for a week and you
know what this is crazy hold your breath
everybody the dog was just fine
just fine just fine um but sometimes she
brings it some sometimes the brain
sometimes they don't but it's something
they always mention because my parents
are
grown-ups
young adults right so you found out
about it late
and then
you're not the bad guy when you said
well that we just found out about this
not cool
right
yeah and i think part of the reason they
felt they could just bring their dog
without asking is because the party was
being
held at my in-laws and they have like an
open door policy to pet
but it was us hosting the party and like
we invited them and we didn't realize
that they weren't candy
it doesn't matter
i know i guess i'm just trying to defend
their side of things but i'm you know i
really don't feel like
all of it's about the dog it's just it
sucks that it's come to this little
thing yes it's not about the dog it's
not about the dog
if it was about the dog this would have
been long gone and over yeah
long gone and over it's stupid you can't
it's it it would have been
so dumb i can't bring my dog you're a
crazy overprotective new mother and you
would have been like well it's crazy
that you can't not have your dog for a
few hours on a saturday and then y'all
would be like i know i know
all right i'll get let's go get beers
and it would have been over right break
that little dialogue and then we all get
over it and still like have the party
have fun yes
even just like them telling us that like
hey they're major offended and maybe we
can reevaluate and figure out a way to
get their dog there and keep it inside
but that wasn't communicated so now it's
like a big thing right here's the true
conversation your husband needs to have
this with his brother
to brother man to man
and i don't mean like some like duel
but
like he needs to call his brother and
say we're you and i are meeting
this isn't a question this is a
statement we're meeting i'll drive down
to philly to talk to you we need to have
this hard conversation what is happening
i'm not interested in going through my
life without my brother in it and my
wife is an integral part of my life your
fiance is about to be a part of your
life which means they're all part of all
of our lives what in the world
that's what needs to happen
yeah
and do you think it's
appropriate to have that conversation
like the four of us versus not them not
yet they need to have it themselves
okay these are two brothers man acting
like
this whole conversation i i thought you
were talking about it was you and him
you and your brother
yeah man these are two brothers and you
don't have a conversation and mom and
dad quite frankly need to butt out of it
yeah
they just need to get over it
yeah i really do feel like the issue is
unfortunately more
my future sister-in-law somehow having
an issue with me so that's why i was
wondering if
probably do it the four of us like not
yet at some point yes if if there's
healing to take place and people are
going to act like grown-ups then yes
it'll probably include you and her
getting in a room and saying i like you
i don't know where we got sideways but
what can we do to move forward right
yeah and um i think the conversation
starts with your brother
because here's what's gonna happen
you're gonna find out that you said
something seven months ago that you have
no recollection of
that hit her in the wrong way on the
wrong day for the wrong reason and it
started a one degree turn sideways
and now it's
it's a mess or she just doesn't like you
and doesn't want to be a part of this
big family and blah blah blah blah blah
at the end of the day doesn't matter
because you can't get in her head
yeah
but here's what
like before we get off the phone hear me
say this
you are responsible for your boundaries
and you are responsible for treating
people with dignity and respect and
kindness
right yeah you cannot control how they
respond and choose to act
and guilt guilt is fine guilt's just a
signal right it's just a it's a feeling
it's good it's important
but it's something you look at because
our feelings don't always tell us the
truth
and i can feel guilty about something i
feel sad for the way somebody feels i
feel bummed out that my in-laws
are mad at me i feel bummed out that my
brother-in-law's fiance is
a middle schooler or not even a middle
schooler or an elementary school kid
um
and then suddenly you deconstruct that
guilt and it's not really guilt at all
it's just sad i'm sad i had a picture
it's grief i i wanted it to be like this
and it actually is like this
yeah and it's a bummer but dude i i
think your brother should call his
brother today
and say just cut through the nonsense
you and i are meeting we gotta figure
this out
i have a feeling my husband's not going
to like that response why why would he
not do that well why don't i call his
brother
i feel like at this point we're just
both like we just want it to be resolved
and like he kind of feels like it's
well i don't know if he feels this way
but i feel like it is more from like my
sister-in-law's future sister-in-law's
side but he doesn't have any business
talking to your brother his brother's
girlfriend
call his brother and say what in the
world because at least his brother's
gonna have a true honest
discussion and if he's already choosing
um if if younger brother is already
choosing fiance over a conversation with
his brother
you you then you have a big neon sign to
where the problem is
yeah
and i i just embrace my heart
breaks my heart but at least when mom
and dad call back he can say hey i
called brother he wants nothing to do
with me
he doesn't want to have a conversation
with me
he's still acting like a middle school
kid blah blah blah sorry i did i reached
out to him i went and visited him he
didn't show up she didn't show up he
won't have an honest truthful
conversation at least you can report
that back up to mother and dad so that
they can call him and say what's the
matter with you i raised you better than
this
but here so everybody listening real
quick
people in your life
are gonna come up with new boundaries
they're gonna say no they're going to
say no thank you or i'm not
that's not
this thing isn't welcome here whether
it's a dog or a pet or your loud
f550 with the with the glass packs on it
or whatever you're doing
fine
cool somebody's put a boundary in and
you don't like that boundary you choose
well then if my f550 can't show up if i
can't show up to your kid's birthday
party with my ar strapped on my back
whatever the thing is if i can't do it
um i'm opting out great opt out but do
it with class and dignity and just say
hey thanks uh we're not gonna make it um
or i'm gonna choose to
um
i travel only with my dog it's helpful
for me and i understand you want my dog
there so that's great so we're going to
pass on the birthday party but we'll
catch up at another time
just being a dole about it to be grown
up about it
and if you're marrying into a family
you're marrying everybody in that family
make peace with it and if you marry
somebody who has a great relationship
with their sibling don't blow that up
honor that love it be so excited about
it
do whatever you can to to nourish that
relationship
conflict deferred is conflict amplified
have the conversation